a Texas agency is threatening to fire
employees if they wear clothing that is
not consistent with their birth
genitalia we've started to suspect that
the transphobic movement of the right
and meshed with the magarite is really
overplaying its hand with the anti-woke
stuff the polling suggests that the
country is far more woke than these
anti-worksters want to pretend it
doesn't seem like this is a way to win
elections and yet they will not stop
this is the latest it's probably illegal
but we will get to that in a moment Vice
news reports Texas agency threatens to
fire people who don't dress quote
consistent with their biological gender
the internal Department memo is just the
latest attempt by state officials in
Texas to crack down on trans and gender
non-conforming people this is the Texas
Department of Agriculture